sur ses terres le long du fleuve
mississippi c'est jouer un des pires
drames de l'histoire des états unis
ici au sud de la louisiane
des dizaines de milliers d'êtres humains
ont souffert le martyr john coming 77
ans riche avocat de la nouvelle orléans
nous ouvre les portes de la plantation
whitney
le premier musée au pays dédié à
l'histoire de l'exclavage des visages
d'esclaves sculpté hante encore les
lieux dans cette église bâtie par des
noirs des statuts d'enfants en terre
cuite nous interpelle chacun d'entre eux
a son histoire
john cummings cherche à investir dans
l'immobilier
quand ils achètent cette plantation en
1999 il découvre les atrocités de l'
esclavage en lisant les titres de
propriété
les annonces lui vint alors l'idée
d'ouvrir un musée dans lequel il
investit 10 millions de dollars il veut
redonner une voix à ces hommes et ces
femmes exploitées nous sommes ici dans
le chant des anges un sanctuaire en
mémoire des enfants d'esclaves morts
avant l'âge de 3 ans tous les noms deux
cent sept mille esclaves de la louisiane
sont gravées dans le granit
sybille edel montréal a eu lien de
parenté avec l'un d'entre eux son
arrière grand père victor edel a vécu
sur cette plantation secrets de famille
longtemps caché il avait une saveur
l'ancien maître des lieux un blanc a eu
un enfant avec une des esclaves noirs
madame aïda morial est une descendante
de cette union est un raciale nous
organisons une rencontre entre elle et
un des petits fils des propriétaires de
la plantation la famille à del mar
millions
cent cinquante ans après l'émancipation
de 4 millions d'esclaves
le malaise persiste elle me levais
charlot pire que le mac
l'historien ibrahima seck dirige la
recherche au musée de la plantation
whitney plusieurs de ces esclaves
viennent du sénégal son pays natal
les etats-unis ont bâti dit il leur
prospérité sur le dos de ces esclaves
marrons souvent de pleurer quand j'ai
fait le tour je ne sais pas très souvent
je suis plus part d'un profond coûte
d'émotion
le passé douloureux que les américains
découvrent en visitant la plantation
pour plusieurs il est temps que les
états unis confronte se passer
d'autres pays dont déjà fait des side
event and found in afrique zain pour une
journée de deuil a assumé son passé au
contraire c'est un match moins le passé
vous parvenez à régler des problèmes le
docteur ibrahima cheikh crois que la
violence de l' esclavage se répercute
encore dans la société américaine
le racisme est toujours là les
descendants des esclaves sont les plus
pauvres sont les plus mauvais les
mauvaises écoles c'est pour eux une
forte proportion de la population
masculine est en prison le crime la
drogue ça tout ça c'est des séquelles de
l'esclavagé ont fait
une peur une méfiance 200 ans
d'esclavagé laisse des marques que même
président noir n'a pu effacer
ouais